why do you think
um
why do you think so many people are
trying to you know silence you from
having people uh hear what you have to
say there's got to be a reason for
somebody to say listen this guy's doing
more harm than good what do you say to
those people
so we're this and it partially relates
to mass formation this theory of
Matthias Desmond not my theory
and it it partially relates it goes back
to a very active campaign to promote two
people for the Nobel Prize if if you
track back to the origin of a lot of
these attacks yeah it goes back to the
very concerted effort that was mounted
by bioentec Pfizer and uh by UPenn to
promote kariko and Weissman for the
Nobel Prize
and they got most of the major prizes
they got the Alaska award which by the
way is managed by an investment fund
um but they didn't get The Nobel and um
it was fascinating watching this play
out it was a standard concerted campaign
and and there is a school of thought
that if one wishes to win the Nobel
Prize you have to use mass media in
order to influence the committee
and so I saw this playing out
particularly my wife did which is what
kind of sparked all of this off is I was
being written out of history in in
Wikipedia and in every other platform
and people were it's basically a Stolen
Valor situation people were taking
credit for what I did in the late 1980s
I've never denied what they did I've
never attacked what they did it is it's
a scientific effort that they why would
they do that because Kai can you do me a
favor can you pull up the article I gave
you
uh from uh uh uh uh I give you an
article uh in regards to who came out
with mRNA if you can pull that article
up it's not that one it's one of the
most recent ones I just sent you this is
the you talking about the nature one uh
that one right there okay so this
article came out because the biggest
thing is I when I go online and I see
where people give you a lot of criticism
is he has on his LinkedIn profile that
he's the inventor of mRNA right that's
what they say so let me kind of put this
on and see what you're going to be
saying so I go online and uh there's
this doctor called doctor uh Eric topple
if I'm pronouncing his last name
correctly or not and he's followed by
some credible people it's not like he's
not followed by credible people he is he
is part of the mainstream narrative has
been for a long time fair enough he said
On a related matter Dr Malone who
asserts he is the inventor of mRNA
vaccine and actively cultivates vaccine
skepticism is not and has admitted that
fact and then he puts the links below
and talking about two other people and
then he brings up this picture of you
and his tweet but if you read this
article go all the way to the top and
the article it says go all the way to
the top all the way to the top how
scientists Drew wise men Med 87 GR rs-87
and Catalan carico developed a
revolutionary mRNA technology inside
covet vaccine while I'm reading through
this article there's not a single
mention of your name in here and then in
the comments section some people say why
if you can do control F-Type and Malone
do control F and type in Malone the only
place you see this is in the Bottom by
John Carter whoever commented this on
January 3rd 2022 which is three days ago
this article is complete rewrite of
history no mention of Dr Malone who
claims to have discovered in vitro and
in Vivo RNA transa of affection at the
Salk Institute in 1987 and that he later
invented mRNA vaccines in 1988 this
pre-dates anything cited here so
you your claim is I'm the inventor of
this
they say you are not they don't mention
any of the names why are they saying
that and why are you saying that you're
the inventor
so the reason that I'm saying it is
because I have nine issued patents that
have my name on it that were filed in
1988 okay okay
um and and this is public information
it's widely available and never cited so
for instance the nature article of the
Tangled history of mRNA vaccines which I
was uh I had I provided that author with
extensive access to deep information
okay including the primary invention
disclosure which I validated by allowing
him to speak enabling him to speak to
the scientist Mark kinde that cross
signed it I think it was 1987 or 1988.
you said enabling him who is him
um speaking of the author of the article
okay um uh in the Tangled history of
mRNA that was published in nature
um that none of these articles have
cited the patents
that have been part of this mainstream
press narrative
all the way through including so this
traces back to the let me let me roll
back a little bit more
Drew Weissman is a Tony fauci postdoc
Katie courico is literally a former
Hungarian spy
can you type that can you type that up
there just type in her name yeah and
type in Hungarian spy because I want us
to uh just go back to the article prior
to that go all the way to the top it's
in the European press my goal is by the
end of the call by the end of the
interview just type in her uh copy paste
her name yeah but I I recommend you
right don't use don't use Google
and then go do copy paste what would you
like us to use
okay go to DuckDuckGo and uh type in her
name and Hungarian spy
Hungarian spice so just so you know
nothing pops up so far
okay
a typical Hungarian story when I was
only getting a spectrum cover 19x and
Canada solicitation there's no more
names I have a Pfizer here we go click
second click Euro News
second one
there you go that's third one I was
innocent this is this is
Soviet air ghost returns to hunt
covid-19 vaccine scientists
Heroes guy has just got a job as drones
with Calgary in 1978 the secret police
knocked on her door Kirk was given a
choice agreed to cooperate with the
communist state security apparatus or
accept that her career in scientific
research was over before it had begun I
knew how the system worked I was afraid
so I signed a recruitment document she
signed she said so this is her response
there's multiple other Publications to
go back and I was contacted by people
from Hungary early on in this and said
look this is what we know about her who
has verified that she was a Hungarian
spider there's a credible multiple
articles do you know any one of them
they can like no okay you can easily
search and find okay so fair enough but
go ahead you're saying so she's a
Hungarian so these two have
um an interesting history background
okay Katie I learned about Katie she
contacted me
um it was almost a decade after I had
done the original work I was working at
UC Davis as an assistant professor okay
and you can find this the the footprints
of this interaction in her first mRNA
related paper
in which she not only cites my work as
as one of the standard academic
citations
but she listens in the acknowledgments
um appreciation for my interaction with
her
she called me I put her in touch with um
Junior people in my laboratory group
another assistant professor I put her in
touch with a professor at UC Riverside
who had done key work in mRNA 5 Prime
and three prime and translated region
act interactions and did anything I
could to help her invited her to a
conference in Annapolis that I had set
up that I was organizing
and and actively tried to help her move
forward with her work this is all
literally of just about a decade after I
did my work
so she is very aware of what I had done
I helped her early on
and then when she and Drew Weissman
wrote their
um initial review paper where they
talked about mRNA and mRNA vaccines
which is what this whole thread builds
off of
they grossly minimized my contributions
why would they do that and how could
they do that it's this is the way
science is science is a wicked
competitive business
and it's easy to do you just it's you
undersight or you miss sight or you fail
to cite so so let me ask you let me ask
you this for me my experience have been
for whatever reason doctors are
extremely arrogant and very cocky almost
like a god uh uh what's the word I'm
looking for uh the hubris might be a
word hubris might be the word but more
like uh the feeling of I'm God I know
what I'm talking about I'm the expert
it's insanely competitive it's all about
money and power so so but here's the
point though when I do a lot of the
research when people come I'm not in
your world so all I'm doing is I'm just
speculating stuff and I'm trying to get
a little bit closer to uh the truth by
uh asking people on both sides so
you know most people will say nobody
ever invented a vaccine it's co-inventor
you did it with a group there was a
group of people that is the criticism so
let me let me give you some feedback
here's a metaphor okay just because a
group of Engineers designed the 737 Max
it doesn't mean that the Wright brothers
didn't invent power flight
the core technology
and the applications are disclosed in
nine issued U.S patents and multiple
foreign patents that were filed in I
think it was March 1988 and another
patent that was filed by the Salk
Institute but dropped and it was filed
on exactly the same day
so there this whole issue this is why I
you know and it's frankly it's my wife
that is really really pissed off about
all of this about this Stolen Valor is
because she lived through it it was an
incredibly stressful period in our time
I don't understand how that's possible
though doc because you know Steve Jobs
can talk about he invented the you know
the technology everybody in the world
knows it's Wozniak you know nobody can
take that credit away from wazing that
was a 1977-76 so there has been a
concerted campaign to write me out of
History all the way through why though
because the Nobel so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]